in melee controllers
are everything a good controller will
allow you to easily pull off moves that
could be nearly impossible otherwise and
a bad
controller well it feels like zay's
doing everything right but was covering
yeah exactly sometimes you do just get
checkmated huh it is a controller issue
100% confirmed yeah yeah he's asking the
crowd for a SP now for years melee die
hards have modded their controllers
doing everything from cutting notches
into the plastic all the way up to
replacing the circuit boards inside them
all to find that slight Edge but the
quest to god tier mod the game and its
controllers alongside the rise of box
controllers has raised an obvious
concern how far is too far what should
actually be allowed in Pro play I hate
this argument that like unless a
terrible player that has never won any
can win a major with it it it's not an
advantage is the hit boox cheating yeah
we've gone too far so it doesn't matter
so should modded controllers and boxes
really be considered cheating or is the
melee Community simply allergic to
change all right so before we get into
the melee controller controversy I need
you to check out our new merch including
our zipup beta hoodie you can do it when
you're at the lake or in the server by
yourself or with the buds never let
anyone tell you it's wrong because
baiting it always feels good a zipup
hoodie made for all those who mastered
the art of baiting check out the score
eorts drop 2 available now okay so since
the early days of Super Smash Brothers
Melee competitors have been on a quest
to find the perfect controller melee
virtuoso Mewtwo king would even show up
to events with a literal bag full of
them it's my mom got me this your mom's
[__] blocking that's what she's doing
it's gotten so bad that there are
players who have actually stepped down
from tournaments because their
controller wasn't performing the way
they wanted it to but why do players
have this obsession with Gamecube
controllers don't they all do basically
the same thing well you see no no they
don't um like at all what's the
difference between One controller and
you ask honestly I don't know what I do
know is that my good buddy Colton would
love to talk you through the many
shortcomings of the GameCube controller
or at the very least he gets paid to so
have at it champ and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
talk about one of the greatest Esports
of all time that just also happens to be
played on controller yeah I'm down for
that so the original GameCube
controllers were a quality assurance
riddle nightmare despite looking nearly
identical on the outside the performance
of any two GameCube controllers can vary
drastically keep flicking left on your
control stick and you can see if I do
that with this controller the control
stick doesn't move to the right at all I
do the same thing with his yeah you can
see it bounce to the right sometimes and
if it does that your controller has snap
back and that results into some improper
reverse neutral bead depending on when
and sometimes even where the controller
was made you could have different boards
wir ing sticks triggers you name it one
could have analog sticks with no
Snapback While others might have severe
Snapback causing players to miss inputs
certain sticks could travel further in
the horizontal Direction giving you an
advantage by letting you move your
character faster than your opponent and
some cases the GameCube controller's
analog sticks weren't even calibrated
correctly out of the box so although you
might be moving the stick all the way to
the left or right they could drift
vertically or not give you the full
range of motion the Springs used in many
triggers can also be quite different
meaning that the force required to fully
press them down varies and because of
these issues many serious players are
constantly on the search for the perfect
controller getting them custom built
with all the parts handpicked from other
GameCube controllers and fine-tuned to
fit their play style as seamlessly as
possible if you're into melee then you
know exactly how good it feels to play
on a perfectly calibrated controller I
don't because I'm God awful at melee but
as a console pleb from the original Xbox
era I have at least some idea at least
more than Demetri and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about now up until 2008 Smashers could
just walk into a game store and buy a
GameCube controller and hope that it
didn't have any of the issues that
Colton mentioned but after Nintendo was
hit by a patent infringement lawsuit
over their Wii Classic GameCube and wave
bird controllers they were no longer
available for purchase in the US and
because third party controllers were
considered pretty bad at the time
American smash players began importing
OEM or original equipment manufacturer
GameCube controllers from Japan Nintendo
appealed the patent infringement claims
and won in 2010 but at that point
players had already found DIY solutions
to make their existing controllers feel
and perform better and one of the most
common mods was literally cutting Shield
drop and fire fox notches into the
controller's analog stick Gates Shield
dropping is a crucial melee technique
that lets a player drop through certain
platforms while they're shielding it's
only possible by pressing a very
specific angle on the controller one
that a custom Notch guarantees every
time meanwhile Firefox notches allow
characters like Fox and Falco to recover
easier and for the player to just
generally have more control over their
movement and this is where we come back
to the fact that original GameCube
controllers are just a crapshoot some
have sticks that just can't shoot Shield
drop 100% of the time most can't even
Shield drop in both directions basically
in melee right now you have like a big
ass Lottery and the lottery tickets are
controllers you buy a new controller and
you're hoping that oh I'm going to win
this time and you don't and they can buy
another 10 controllers and it still
might not be like the way it should be
in competitive melee controllers are
banned if they have turbo buttons
programmable macros or interfere with
the game itself and notched controllers
technically don't do any of this but
once players began adding their own
notches some in the community were upset
that Advanced Techniques that they'd
spent years mastering were now being
trivialized by mods I don't understand
why like because the notches change that
doesn't mean they're not broken you have
to keep taking steroids so steroids
isn't broken like this guy is so stupid
melee is a game where the one with the
most skill should win no doubt about
that however players seem to almost ftiz
a very arbitrary skin especially that
which ends up becoming muscle M doing
perfect angles is not muscle memory as
for players at the top level I'd
honestly be surprised if Armada SL mut
didn't in caps of course have custom
notches for those angles they don't I
know this he should know that I know
which controller of a has because I stay
with him I hate this argument that like
unless a terrible player that has never
won anything can win a major with it it
it's not an advantage leen's strong
opinions haven't always been well
received by the community especially
when he speaks his truth literally
minutes after losing I think there
should be something that at least makes
things run on time I mean you don't have
to agree with me but I I personally P
this year I won't be competing in Mele
if there's no installing rules for a
long time lean advocated against the use
of controller notches he believed that
using any controller that wasn't OEM was
basically cheating and just generally
lowered melee's skill ceiling but
despite his protests the majority of the
community remained divided on the issue
some players believed that notches
should be allowed While others thought
that melee should be played with
standardized GameCube controllers after
all that's how the game was designed to
be played the modding Community
continued to innovate though and custom
controllers became more than just a gam
pad they became works of art JP white
shell custom transparent salmon buttons
and SE stick pink paracord and it lights
up okay it's a bit flamboyant but there
are a lot of practical modifications in
this thing too Shield drop and Firefox
notches a snapback capacitor a tactile Z
button and shorten Springs in both
triggers this was
$400 as you can see custom GameCube
controllers can get pretty pricey some
people spend hundreds of dollars just to
get the exact look and feel that they
want for some some it's even become
something of a hobby some players have
even started installing new motherboards
into their GameCube controllers shell to
stop stick degradation mind you people
have had some mixed results there it
feels like zay's doing everything right
but was covering exactly sometimes you
do just get checkmated huh it is a
controller issue 100% confirmed yeah
yeah he's asking the crowd for SP but in
2017 Game Dev and former melee
competitor Dan salvato released a mod
for the game that could solve all of
those pesky controller problems without
spending a penny if your opponent has a
controller that can achieve near-perfect
consistency but your controller randomly
fails then you're at an automatic
disadvantage before the match even
begins we believe that this unfair
imbalance and excessive controller
hunting needs to stop and that's why we
developed a solution UCF is a set of
codes that allows any controller to
perform just as well as what you'd
consider the perfect GameCube controller
to be the mod doesn't make any
techniques easier and it's it does not
enable players to perform actions
differently from how they used to the
changes only let you do what's possible
with a perfect controller in vanilla
melee now all of that sounds amazing in
theory this would eliminate the need for
shield notches and other mods people
have been making to their controllers
over the years everyone would finally be
on equal footing right well over the
years Nintendo has made it very clear
that they do not allow modifications now
it's pretty hard to tell if UCF is on by
looking at the game so using it for
events has become something of an Open
Secret The Players likely know because
their uncalibrated controllers are
finally working as intended but to the
viewers it all looks the same so that
should be the end of this whole debacle
right well not exactly you see over the
past 5 years hitbox style stickless
controllers have made their way into the
melee scene and caused quite a stir
there are buttons that correspond to
each input on a GameCube controller but
products like the Smashbox frame one and
the Box allow for for arguably even more
Precision than you could ever get on
original Hardware but for smash players
box controllers may represent even more
of an advantage the button placement can
make the timing for certain mechanics
like Shield dropping much easier and
more consistent not to mention that
their ergonomic design makes them
preferable for players who suffer from
hand pain from using standard issue
controllers and similar to the notch
debate many players refuse to embrace
this new meta this of course includes
Leen but for once he's not in a small
vocal minority many top players believe
that boxes should either be banned or
just nerfed in some way I'm like very
tempted to like be the trend Setter for
this and like potentially do what I did
for ultimate coin box it it'll probably
give me a lot of flack but like you
don't know how badly I want to Mango Zay
me you ask any of the top six players
they'd be like yes go for it but box
style controllers grew in popular
popularity during the pandemic when all
the events were being held online and
monitoring input wasn't exactly the
easiest thing to do hitboxes in general
are a pretty controversial topic within
the fgc we even made an entire video
about it last year but the difference
between a GameCube controller and a box
style controller is much larger than the
difference between a fight stick and a
hitbox and it's unlikely that most
players are going to make that kind of
switch but even players like lein who
are historically anti- change have
dedicated time learning to play with a
hit box so they wouldn't fall behind
their opponents although he previously
fought against the use of notches and
boxes he now believes that the battle is
essentially lost like I'm going to be
honest the fact that people have used
box for this long for like 5 years and
the fact that hasn't gun Nerf there's no
way you can't know how broken this is I
feel like they're just
unintentionally lying when they say that
it's not a big Advantage needless to say
it's been a pretty jarring period of
transition for the smash community at
this point most top players have just
accepted that even though they may not
like the use of boxes they kind of just
have to suck it up is the hit boox are
macros cheating yeah we've gone too far
so it doesn't matter you don't care
anymore so if you're facing someone
you're like whatever um I my whole thing
is we either ban it or we just shut the
up and play and uh it's not getting
banned so I just try to you know like I
don't want to play somebody on it and
like already go into the set like mad
about it it's like well you know got to
deal with it since it's not getting
banned you just what's the point of
complaining right and ultimately that's
melee sure it may not be the way the
game was meant to be played but nothing
the smash scene does is melee the way it
was meant to be played plus it's not
like to's are going to just inspect
every player's controller to see if
they've carved their own notches so if
those truly help to improve players
gaming experiences they might as well
use them mango said it best shut up and
play it's not like a better controller
is going to turn a scrub into a god so
maybe the debate is best settled on
FD thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and Tik
Tok